daniel thibault sébastien bovet bonsoir
bonsoir
le chiffre mais chaque fois ça me
renverse 830 jour imaginé de détention
pour les deux canadiens entendent
rapidement monsieur trudeau qui
commentait la présence de diplomates
étrangers venus appuyer le canada et les
canadiens surtout encore la chine doit
comprendre que leur approche de
diplomatie coercitive ne fonctionne pas
j'étais à encourager touché de voir le
nombre de diplomates de différents pays
incluant les états unis qui se sont
présentés à dents pour pourra pour le
procès même si ils n'ont pas eu accès il
était là pour démontrer leur solidarité
non seulement avec les deux canadiens
détenus mais pour les principes de droit
et de justice qui doivent être respectés
dans le monde
daniel thibault on refera pas toute
l'histoire on a beaucoup parlé en début
d'émission mais quelques mots du trou
d'eau qui espère vraiment l'entrée en
scène de monsieur bail d'une part pour
dénouer tout seul la communauté
internationale c'est un bon coup le
gouvernement canadien est assez fier
d'avoir réussi à convaincre cette
cinquantaine plus de pays de ceux de se
joindre à ce mouvement là pour dénoncer
ces diplomatie coercitive comme
l'appelle monsieur trudeau et première
éléments puis le deuxième élément paix
monsieur à jurado en point presse l'a
dit ce matin quand on lui a demandé les
américains rencontrent les chinois le
présentement un cottage en alaska
je savais qu'il va permettre à monsieur
baden d'élaborer sa politique à
l'endroit de la chine et on a demandé à
monsieur très doux est ce que vous
pensez que le dossier va être abordé
puis le jilbab oui je m'y attends ont
misé là dessus parce qu'on pense que ça
peut mettre de la pression en même temps
ben et vous l'avez dit le 800 à 830 jugé
plus 850 milles 130 jours c'est énorme
ça va se régler demain matin mais on
veut augmenter la pression sur pékin
pour tenter de faire bouger les choses
très bien sébastien et daniel la
vaccination et parlons une seconde on va
revoir la courbe de la différence entre
le québec et l'ontario l'ontario dit on
va prendre les bouchées doubles
lorsqu'on a une autre stratégie
n'empêche
sébastien au québec ont pu souffler un
peu cette partie là va bien la foule de
dire oui c'est parti là va bien parce
qu'on a pris la décision taux de
n'injecter que la première dose en
ontario sont fait rien ils ont injecté b
2e div
aussi alors la décision d'injecter la
première dose d'attendre 90 jours ou 120
jours avant la deuxième dose fait en
sorte qu' on essaie on a des chiffres
meilleurs que d'autres provinces c'est à
dire que on a en a vacciné 10% de la
population à la première dose donc une
décision c'est n'diaye médical qui a été
prise mais qui a un effet sur
espère-t-on l'immunisation des gens les
plus vulnérables en leur donnant la
première dose
on les immunise à soit 80 90 % et donc
on peut revenir graduellement un
semblant de vie normale
oui le québec fait bien mais c'est parce
qu'il a utilisé une stratégie qui
consiste à injecter d'abord la première
d'auge au plus grand nombre possible et
de manière générale danielle on le voit
le monsieur trudeau et 7 ce fait du
faqih pas non si beaucoup plus de
dommages que ce qui était prévu puis
est-ce que c'est calculé ans j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas là les trois
quatre cinq prochaines semaines là c'est
que des doses massives qui arrivent au
pays
ça rentre ça arrive ça arrive tellement
puis et monsieur trudeau madame anna
d'aujourd'hui disait on a même certaines
compagnies qui vont envoyer leurs leur
cargaison en deux vagues
parce que on pense que c'est plus
efficace comme ça alors essentiellement
le pari dont on a parlé sur ce forum et
sur d'autres au début au début de
l'année où on disait monsieur trudeau il
n'arrête pas de dire car il va capable
de livrer la marchandise avant la fin du
31 mars qu'on va être capable de livrer
les 6 millions de doses qui avaient été
promises et ses terrasses est un pari
risqué bas clairement il y avait qu il y
avait entre les mains de l'information
qui lui permettait de quoi qui allait y
arriver puis la basse et des millions de
doses qui entend toutes les semaines et
on ne peut pas encore calculé là dedans
les doses supplémentaires de chance de
jen hsun d'astrazeneca qui vont négocier
plus tard deuxième trimestre troisième
trimestre ça fonctionne on est
relativement satisfait du côté d'ottawa
de la façon dont ça se déroule aussi
dans les provinces
on a l'impression que le message est
entendu que le réseau d'accès souhaite
en place un petit peu plus longues se
compliquer en ontario on avait
décentralisé on laissait beaucoup
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre aux
autorités de santé publique locale
sébastien elle disait on a beaucoup misé
sur la deuxième dose en ontario il ya
compté 300 milles ontariens qui ont eu
des gens la deuxième dose parce que
c'était ce constat fait dire au début
c'est là dessus qu'on a on a donné le
capteur photo jour d'hui qd on a pris
cette décision alors québec ont appris
une autre on re vise un peu le csa ne
pas dire que les doses qui travaillent
dans les congélateurs sont pas dire que
ça va plus lentement savait simplement
dire que la stratégie est un peu
différente
quelqu'un disait on a tout de même en
ontario la date cible c'est le 20 juin
on pense que le 20 juin tout le monde va
avoir été en mesure tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est ce qu'on dit au revoir est
en mesure d'avoir au moins une
alors c'est pas que ça va plus lentement
c'est qu'on a adopté une stratégie une
stratégie différente
ça semble vouloir fonctionner quand même
mais le problème le problème pour
l'instant c'est pas l'approvisionnement
2012 vont arriver puis en théorie on va
avoir à ces doses pour vacciner tout le
monde au pays sans aucun problème le
défi c'est les vaccinateurs c'est les
provinces qui doit injecter d'un bras de
leurs citoyens
ça représente un véritable défi
aujourd'hui au québec on a mis les
entreprises d'un coup pour accélérer sa
mais un moment donné va falloir vacciner
plus que trente ou quarante mille
personnes au québec
nous allons monter à 70 80 90 milles par
jour
l'ontario on pousse vers les pharmacies
beaucoup comme on le fait pour la grippe
saisonnière parce qu'il fonctionne pense
que l'exil et vincent choisi
rejoignez nous joignez vous à nous
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez écouté chef
conservateur on a parlé hier le congrès
qui a débuté congrès virtuel c'est comme
ça pour cette année extrait du chef qui
reconnaît philippe vincent que le parti
doit changer peut pas penser qu'avec la
même recette
il va remporter la prochaine bataille
électorale ouais c'est ce qui est vrai
no to le dit d'entrée de jeu dans son
discours les îles canada a changé le
parti aussi doit changer donc ça est son
discours commence vraiment sur un
plaidoyer pour des pour faire les choses
différemment vous pouvez pas comme
militant espérer que avec les mêmes
idées qu'on avait aux deux dernières
élections qu'on soit capable de
convaincre des électeurs supplémentaires
alors qu'on n'a pas été capable de le
faire aux deux dernières élections et on
peut pas non plus compter sur le fait
que justin trudeau va commettre des
erreurs foule battre pour le plan des
idées sur le plan des politiques non
plus que monsieur o'toole disait
d'entrée de jeu on peut l'écouter
le canada a changé notre parti doit
changer aussi
[Musique]
m
le fardeau est de notre côté on dit il
et appel aux nationalistes du québec
appelle en français message que monsieur
au tout la livre aux nationalistes en
dix ans on a besoin de vous c'était
aussi un clin d'oeil aux conservateurs
de l'ouest on ne peut pas gagner la
prochaine élection si on fait bien dans
certaines régions mais qu'on en laisse
d'autres de côté notamment au québec
notamment dans les régions francophones
aussi du reste du pays donc il y avait
cette main tendue la cet appel aux
québécois ont nationaliste et aux ordres
de dire venez au parti conservateur
vous faites partie de la solution le
présenter un plan de relance économique
aussi où on a vraiment les thèmes plus
consensuel du parti conservateur lutte à
la corruption reprise économique santé
mentale aussi pour les canadiens mais on
va l'écouter sur le plan pour les
nationalistes où il revient avec cette
idée de rapport d'impôt unique qui
finalement monsieur otto dix il est
toujours pour la langue française n'est
pas seulement une utile de communication
elle fait partie de l'identité de notre
pays
c'est un héritage qu'il faut préserver
c'est pourquoi j'ai une vie les
nationalistes québécois fédéralistes ou
autonomistes à venir partager le pouvoir
avec moi à toi
nous allons former une grande coalition
comme ceux maîtresse
bon tour de table là dessus parce qu'il
a besoin évidemment de l'ontario il va
sans dire
il a besoin du québec aussi de faire
mieux daniel voilà alors qu faire
grossir a grandi relatant la fameuse
tente bleue faire rentrer davantage de
gens à l'intérieur c'est un beau
discours d'intention ça fonctionne
monsieur un automne au moins le mérite
de d'admettre que effectivement si on
réutilise le même discours qu'ont
utilisés les deux dernières fois on peut
pas s'attendre un résultat très très
différents il ya des éléments
intéressants entre autres sur la
question du changement climatique ou du
bon il y en a un problème mais dans la
même veine il dit n'est pas question de
poursuivre la solution sur une taxe sur
le carbone c'est quoi un refuge des
prêts à faire encore alors quelle est la
solution c'est là dessus qu'on va juger
sur ce qu'il va mettre sur la table ce
qu'il va proposer comme option comme
solution pour lui pour son parti et
c'est là dessus que les électeurs vont
devoir déterminer s'ils sont prêts à
aller faire un tour dans cette grosse
bulle mais aussi sur les changements
climatiques c'est important mais la
relance économique est encore plus
importante donc l'économie prime encore
dans discours conservateur
oui il était quartier car tenez entre
l'ouest et l'ontario et le québec où il
ya davantage de gens dans les grandes
villes qui pensent que ce sujet l'oeil
est incontournable que la taxe carbone
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et peut-être
l'instrument le plus efficace avoir à
voir sébastien il aimerait bien monsieur
legault se fâche encore parce que
monsieur le gouverneur fait que trudeau
télé petit oiseau qui tournait autour
d'eux c'était extraordinaire
choteau l'aimerait bien sûr legault
salle appuyé ouvertement comme le fera
pas ça mais que dans un message qui
aimerait bien que ce soit en poste
oui puis monsieur le goût avait dit
ouvertement qu'il allait magazine et 10
appui au fédéral pour si ses propres
revendications au québec ils l'espèrent
ils espèrent avoir une oreille attentive
des rondes autour de moi j'écoutais
monsieur roux tour puis je venais besoin
qu'ils voulaient injecter une dose de
pragmatisme à ses militants disent à
regarder si vous voulez qu'on prenne le
pouvoir il faut comprendre un peu dans
le rang qu'on soit dans le courant
dominant passez votre tour la droite
religieuse passez votre tour les anti
avortement
il faut qu'on change de discours il faut
qu'on arrête de tirer ce boulet l'a donc
pragmatisme si vous voulez atteindre le
pouvoir et la deuxième chose que il doit
faire pipi mme g pas s'il est réussi à
le faire je n'ai pas écouté tous les
discours mais j'en écoutais des boues
site se définir lui même c'est qu'
arnaud tour si on vote conservateur on
vote pour qui on va te pourquoi il n'a
pas réussi à le faire jusqu'à maintenant
et c'est une occasion ici ça va pas tout
le définir mais joe kay troupe commence
à savoir pourquoi on va trés si on vote
et renault tout le procès de lampard
mais d'annoncer passeront de campagne
mais s'il y en a une ne faisons pas
l'erreur collectivement de penser qu'il
ait battu nécessairement là maintenant
on peut découvrir cet homme là comme
tout au début les gens avaient une très
bonne impression mais il sait comme il
sera en charge et dans plusieurs
contradictions de son parti mais bref
c'est pas joué cette histoire là il n'y
a pas été clairement il n'y a pas été
clairement défini au palais de
définition le justement la scène avant
tout l'occasion pour le définir et
définir de façon négative alors y'a
encore du temps devant lui sa campagne
commence bientôt ils le temps compté
mais il peut faire le travail
et puis il ya paris qui est fait dans le
discours reste un peu spéciale aussi vu
quitter virtuel on n'a pas la réaction
de la salle on évoque comment les
militants réagissent donc si on va
peut-être le savons un peu demain gagne
une séance de questions réponses avec
les militants mais son pari se dit
regardez je sais qu'à l'ouest on sera
peut-être pas à ses défenseurs du
pétrole défenseur de vos industries
je sais que je vais en décevoir certains
mais il faut vraiment qu'on se retrouve
au centre pour aller que vous lisez les
électeurs puissent défendre les libéraux
comme metal parties extérieures terminé
merci beaucoup bon congrès fait les vins
sans merci daniel narcisse sébastien
fallu malgré un tour pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit